all right guys
bang bang got nick here with me thank
you so much for doing this
hey hi so i want to start first with
this idea that uh you've built one of
the largest unicorns in europe
and specifically have this idea of kind
of a financial super app right anyone in
the world can show up to revolut store
and you're able to service their
financial service needs maybe let's just
talk about where the idea for this came
from and kind of
why you're going after this uh
opportunity so initially it served from
my
own problem so obviously i was expert
living in uk so i traveled abroad and
also i sent their
money abroad a lot and i was always
pissed off
by commissions the banks charged me
and then i came up with a with a simple
solution it's effectively a global
account plus account which allowed you
to
send and spend money at interbank rates
but then our last five years we really
expanded the product to
to super concept so the new value
proposition is uh
rather simple so we give you all your
financial services products that you
need for your daily life
are 10 times cheaper and 10 times better
compared to banks or stock brokers
or so on and then the idea is that all
these products are highly personalized
to your needs because they all
talk with each other so we actually save
you a lot of time by just you know
opening one account within two minutes
for uh probably at retail and then
secondly we
allow you to have all these products
either for free
or at significant discounted prices
compared to banks so you can trade with
us
stock trading for free obviously
currency exchanges for free
and so on and so on so we save you money
and then we make it
in a nice user from the way for sure and
what's so fascinating is you talk about
kind of your prior experience really
driving a lot of uh not only the
philosophical
approach that you have but a lot of the
features that you guys have built um
you spent time uh as a equity
derivatives trader at uh
lehman and a few other places uh when
you started to build out the actual
financial service technologies
how much of your experience uh from the
trader side kind of played into this
versus it was just more of your personal
experience with financial service
platforms
a good question to balance your when i
started doing this business uh
i was shocked because you know i didn't
really know anything so then any
payments or i didn't know
acquiring so i had to learn everything
from scratch
so the idea to start this business was
or
well obviously i was like equity
derivatives trader and i realized how
much money
i wasted on banking fees
but that's the only thing that actually
helped me to build this business
everything else i had to learn from
scratch
yeah so if i'm a retail investor today
or a business owner i can use uh the
software that you guys have built
let's start maybe with the retail trader
first uh or kind of a regular investor
every day person
i come in what are all the features that
are available to me
so ultimately for uh stock traders and
crypto traders
uh at the moment we give you access to
all
our u.s stocks we're shortly uh giving
you access to
european stocks so the whole idea is
that account
is global for you to trade right so you
obviously
if you're in us you load your dollars
but then you can trade
every asset out there without actually
incurring commissions and
without incurring fx fees just to give
you some numbers
to compare so whenever you open a
development us
stockbroker account and you trade
for example european-based stocks
australian stocks or japanese stocks
uh there is a currency conversion fee
involved and at least half percent
sometimes 61 percent
so whatever you trade your two-way
ticket is
at least one percent cost to you so we
help you to to avoid this cost
and plus on top of it we always have a
very nice
interface very easy to use got it and so
what is
what like is the difference of the user
behaviors that you've seen
over the last 12 18 months right
obviously we've got uh
kind of covid happened you saw all sorts
of uncertainty um
but then also we saw this kind of
historic monetary policy decisions
uh across different geographies what
changed in user behavior
or the specific kind of insights that
you have watching how users use the uh
use the platform over the last 12 to 18
months
so basically because we have one up
combining all the financial services
that people use
in in their daily lives so we can
clearly observe for a change
in their behaviors so first obvious
spending
went down a lot like all the categories
such as travel
restaurants bars decreased
at least by 60 70 percent and then where
we see a lot of people starting actually
putting this money into their
stock trading account and then buying
stocks
so interest in stock trading probably
double to tripled
during this period of time crypto
at least three to five x compared to
what we see in the pre-code
so in short people are have excess money
because they cover spending and they put
this excess money into
assets trading assets yeah what's so
fascinating is uh
here in the united states we definitely
saw a savings rate went up personal
income rate went up
uh and then you have kind of hard data
and you can actually see and measure on
the platform
that a lot of that excess cash was going
right into stock trading accounts or
into crypto trading accounts
but it sounds like um the crypto
accounts actually had kind of a higher
lift than the stock trading accounts
is that just kind of a base effect where
crypto was smaller before and so it's
easier to kind of multiply it
or was there actually more cash inflow
into crypto than maybe the stock
accounts
yeah i think we saw probably double or
cash flow in crypto compared to
stock in florida so if you look at our
balances and compare
crypto versus stocks so crypto will be
double competitive stocks
i mean that's pretty incredible um talk
to me about the
the business account so i think this is
probably one of the most fascinating
parts of what you guys are doing where
uh most folks who have tried to build uh
kind of these super apps or one-stop
shops for financial services they really
pick
one vertical right so they say hey we're
gonna go after retail
or we're going to go after kind of the
institutional client or we're going to
go after enterprises
and those are really kind of three
different platforms you guys have
uh these business accounts right next to
the individuals and so maybe talk a
little bit about what a business can do
on the platform
uh and then kind of why adding business
accounts alongside of what the everyday
person could use
so the main available position is again
are allowing businesses to use all
financial services they need
under one umbrella so you can open
account within five minutes
online and then you've got access
obviously to your bank accounts in
multiple currencies
you can do payments globally plus you
can acquire
cards or require payments online or
offline
below acquiring solution so think about
it as
citigroup plus tripe plus your payroll
provider under under one umbrella
and they're at price significantly
cheaper compared to any other providers
so that's advantage number one and
advantage number two we are allowing you
to do global business from from day one
because obviously all the accounts are
global right you have multiple
currencies you can
send and receive payments from your
local suppliers
and then also you can sell globally as
well you can sell in u.s you can sell in
uk
you can sell in europe australia and so
on
and plus on the top of it we save you a
lot of money because of all this you
know cross-border fees cross currency
fees
uh overall it's a very beneficial
products especially for people who just
start their own business
we give them ability to sell globally
yeah what's so fascinating about this is
obviously coming out of covid
um it seems like remote work uh kind of
the digital economy
uh has become much more prevalent in a
lot of businesses that maybe weren't
online uh now are coming online very
quickly but also people starting
businesses
they're basically global on day one
right i remember maybe a decade ago
or maybe even you know eight eight years
ago uh businesses basically let's say
would start in the united states they
would penetrate the us market and it
would be a pretty big decision almost
like an executive or a board level
decision
okay this is going to be the year of
international expansion they would try
to go push into other markets
but today businesses basically when they
turn on on day one they're global and so
having that financial infrastructure it
sounds like that's really what you guys
are trying to serve is
being able to have a global business
from day one and not have to worry about
all of the various countries the
different accounts and all the different
fee structures
exactly yeah that's exactly our value
proposition for
for businesses plus on top of it will
also automate all your processor will
automatically payroll
where automatically acquiring where to
make a bank account so you don't
really need to run kind of any
spreadsheets or any
uh programmatic interfaces for software
or outside of
the business yeah one of the best ways
to build a valuable company is to just
replace whatever spreadsheets people
have buried somewhere in their uh
inside of their business for sure uh
speaking of
kind of different geographies i know
that one of the focuses for
revolut during 2021 has been geographic
expansion uh you've recently
come to the united states i know that
you're pushing into asia maybe talk a
little bit about
uh kind of the penetration that you have
in europe and then
uh really what the catalyst has been for
your own geographic expansion globally
so if you look at europe we quite being
traded into europe and then in some
countries we achieve
more than 50 percent our penetration so
for example if you look at ireland
one in every two adults in ireland they
are using uh revolut products
and then the reason why we're actually
running these two products one retail
one business
it's really two ecosystems so our goal
is to put these two ecosystems together
and enable businesses and consumers
transact
without intermediaries so what it means
in practice our
consumers and businesses will be able to
avoid all the acquiring fees
or issuing fees scheme fees as a result
the transactions become
are perfectly free and instant and
secondly what we're trying to achieve
we're trying to
enable businesses to sell directly to to
replace customers
through a very simple product very
similar to what facebook will
do but we we call it the mission out
when the
one i mentioned i can go in in the
business account and then set up certain
budget
and then put certain discounts on their
products then these products will be
automatically meshed
with the types of people who have
similar transactions
before and this magic is actually much
more precise compared to google and
facebook because
we own transactions of consumers who
know where they spend a lot of what they
like
as a result conversion for purchasing uh
becomes
much higher compared to google and
facebook and it's a win-win
information they make a sale and then
for customers they
they get a purchase at a discounted
price
got it and so when you start to think
about uh the various geographies one of
the things that uh in the united states
specifically but i think also some of
the european companies
that the knock against them or the
critique is oh these fintech companies
you know they're trying to skirt the law
they're trying to kind of avoid the
regulations that a traditional financial
institution would have to
uh follow for you though i think that
you guys uh i've read online have
applied for a u.s bank
license i think in europe you've also
applied for that license and so maybe
talk a little bit just about
uh the idea behind getting the banking
license and kind of really it almost
feels like take
brand new technology and kind of
superior user experience and software
but also leverage all of the kind of
components of the legacy system and kind
of bring this together to provide the
best experience for
for users well ultimately when we
initially launched the product we
launched it without making a license and
it was a partnership for the bank or in
some branches it was like a lighter
license so what we learned is that
it's very difficult almost impossible to
to merge our tech
with existing legacy compliance and
infrastructure banks so partnerships are
usually
very difficult to do because we are very
differently built
and our systems don't really talk with
expressions of banks there's a problem
so we we decided to go for banking
license in almost every single country
where we're in purely to to control
infrastructure and to provide the best
experience for consumers
plus on top of it banking licenses allow
you to monetize better
and also provide the deposit insurance
for for your consumers
yeah makes uh makes a ton of sense um
one of the things that's fascinating to
me
is uh it feels like over the last 12
months 15 months
you saw all of that user behavior
changing from
uh what i'd consider kind of the more
traditional financial services
uh things like the deposit accounts etc
uh and a big shift into the crypto
trading and uh stock trading
talk a little bit about uh almost a
renewed focus it seems like you guys
have on those products and kind of what
you're building there to help service
some of the clients and really just
empower them to do what they're trying
to do on the platform
yeah so we're obviously as we observe
consumers going into
our wealth management stock trading
crypto trading
we increase our efforts in building new
products for them
for example recently we launched our
social trading so the way it
works are you able to see a
leaderboard with all top traders on
revolution
and then you'll be able to follow them
and then
see what they do what they buy what they
sell second position of their portfolio
see their returns so in short you can
you know just follow what they do
that's number one number two we're
obviously are into crypto so at the
moment we have
well quite quite relational for tokens
and then we are working actually on
uh enabling everyone to deposit
uh crypto in our wallet another draw
crypto
uh from from our world plus on top of it
we are working on not paying interest
on on your deposits in crypto it was
kind of
high level overview what we're done what
are our plans
got it and then when you start to see uh
the stock and crypto trading
um i don't know if you know this data
off the top of your head but uh i'm
assuming that
most of the users that are really kind
of pushing into the crypto trading are
probably younger
they probably have smaller balances i
think we kind of see this across the
industry
uh but is there a lot of overlap between
the people who are using the crypto
trading features and the crypto trading
accounts with the stock or do you feel
like these are pretty segmented and you
know some people want to trade stocks
some people want to trade crypto but
there's not a ton of overlap there
it's rather segmented i would say so we
see a lot of interest
from crypto and then we see a lot of
people trading
our stocks so usually for
if you look at data probably if you look
at crypto traders
probably eighty percent just rate crypto
and twenty percent i tried stocks and
crypto
yeah it's pretty uh pretty crazy to
think how segmented it is almost two
different kind of worlds two different
financial systems being built there
um what's uh been kind of the lessons
that you've seen from the gamestop
the amc uh kind of all these meme stocks
and kind of the reddit crowd
i'm assuming that's driving some
tailwind in stock trading in general but
any lessons learned there are insights
as this has kind of become more
prevalent financial markets
well lesson number one is your
infrastructure should be as stable as
possible right and then be able to take
10x and even in a 20x load while these
things happen
because otherwise you know if your
infrastructure cannot handle the load
then
you'll have a lot of complaints from
consumers you'll have
problems with regulators so generally it
makes sense to
overpay for your cloud providers but to
be able to
to have a very high load yeah and so
really it's a
technical infrastructure uh kind of
problem more than anything right it
sounds like uh kind of these surges of
interest
is something that previously either
hadn't happened or were hard to kind of
anticipate
and the approach that you guys have
taken is just uh almost overkill right
have so much infrastructure availability
and have the elasticity to kind of bring
it online as quickly as possible
to serve these moments of surge of
interest and trading volume
yeah exactly so it actually makes sense
to
to run a huge over capacity just to
ensure that
our peak loads is fulfilled
hey guys what's going on before we
continue with this awesome episode i
want to quickly talk about our sponsor
kraken
for the last 10 years kraken has built
one of the best platforms to buy and
sell cryptocurrencies online
they've got a brand new mobile app the
kraken app today you can go on and buy
bitcoin
or up to 60 of the most popular
cryptocurrencies in the world
and you can do that on the go 24 7.
all you have to do is simply download
the app connect your bank account
and you can get started investing with
as little as 10
it only takes a minute to get started
with the new kraken app you'll have your
portfolio
in your pocket you can track your
portfolio see who the winners and losers
are every day
track your favorite project or just
simply look at the trading volume for
your favorite assets
it has all the features you need without
any of the complexity
it's simply the best place to buy and
sell cryptocurrencies
so go to kraken.com bang bang to learn
more
or go to your favorite app store and
simply search the word kraken and you
can download the mobile app there
crackit's been a long time supporter of
this show so to say thanks it would mean
the world to me if you would go and
download their new mobile app
all right let's get back into this
episode i hope you're enjoying this one
i want to switch gears talk a little bit
about 2020 and into 2021
you're the ceo of a multi-billion dollar
company that has you know tens of
millions of users
uh you guys do i think uh hundreds of
millions of transactions per year
uh any lessons learned over the last 12
to 15 months in terms of
uh the pandemic uh and the monetary
policy kind of experiments that are
going on
right as you sit in that kind of ceo
seat um
when you look back over that time period
like what are some of the lessons that
you take away and you're like wow you
know
uh this was either surprising to me or
things that i wish i had known
uh going into the year i think what i
learned personally
what the whole company learned is uh it
pays off
to be extremely uh tight
it costs right you know before 2020
uh we're running as usual startup right
so we were hiring a lot of people
we didn't really care about you know
costs but as as coveted hit
and obviously our business was very
payment dependent service
revenues you know going down um 40
so we were very fast at you know cutting
costs you know ensuring that our in in
economics
is great but ultimately for for startups
that are less fast
it could have been a very troubling
experience
so even you know it is now almost over
we still
are very tight with constantly in
economics
yeah it's interesting you describe kind
of pre uh
covered that you're more of a payments
business would it be fair to say that
uh you would categorize yourself as
someone that asked you know two years
ago hey we're more of a payments
business than anything
and now this is more of kind of a
brokerage type business or how would you
think about that transition between uh
where
you get most of the volume and revenue
from for the business
initially we're definitely into into
payments business more than our
70 percent of revenue came from payments
now we make probably less than 30
percent
from payments and then the rest is being
made on our other other types of
businesses
so we definitely diversified her a lot
and coit actually helped us to shift as
well
yeah it's uh it's fascinating to kind of
see and you know you guys probably
won't get enough credit but uh to you
know make a transition like that
uh with the speed that you did given the
size that you were and the user base
that you had
i'm sure it's not easy um one of the
other things that's fascinating to me
about you specifically
is uh as the ceo of a multi-billion
dollar business and one of the largest
unicorns in europe
do you feel pressure to kind of be
successful because you feel like uh that
the european
tech industry is kind of counting on you
to to be the example of hey successful
companies can be built here in europe or
or how do you think about uh kind of the
position that you're in
or the companies in uh in light of kind
of the local tech community
uh across all the european countries
well to be honest i never think about it
uh european tech versus you know asian
tigers uh u.s tech
uh another way in business and we need
to compete
within this niche and we want to be
number one in it
and then i focus every day that the
company
produces number one product and then our
financials are also number one
across you know the category of digital
banking yeah and when you think about
that
what are some of the things in the
future kind of on the horizon that
will help kind of vault you guys to
number one and stay there
uh in terms of features are the things
that the user base wants
uh that you're excited about or kind of
thinking through how to bring that to
them
we've got quite a few for example our
product number one that we already built
and we are in tasty phase so it's travel
related
so we we we bet that you know a lot of
people will return to trouble and then
there will be
a huge spike in travel activities so we
build a product
within our marketplace within our hub
you
effectively have equivalent of
booking.com or expedia so it's our
interface everything is ours you can
book
stays or hotels you know houses at the
same price as booking.com and expedia
plus on top of it you can get
10 percent cash back instantly so it's
exactly the same experience
same prices plus on top of it uh 10
cashback
so that's probably number one product
number two that we built during uh
pandemic
uh is actually credit related
uh so basically it's called seller
advance
and then the way it works or as soon as
you connect your
seller to to our account uh you are able
to
withdraw your salary much well
before that your salary is being paid so
how it works in practice for example if
you are being paid on
30th of every month and today is 15 you
can get 50
of your salary upfront got it so
basically the whole idea is
uh you can get access to the cash and
there's some underwriting that's going
on in terms of you guys are fronting
that money
there's probably a little bit of uh of a
fee that you're taking
for that and uh what it really does is
uh it allows you to not have to wait for
that next paycheck if they need to
you know some sort of expense et cetera
exactly so we will
underwrite your salary that will allow
you to withdraw your salary early
proportionally to accrued days yeah
what's fascinating about this
is um you know i think it's the top four
banks
uh in 2019 made about eight billion
dollars in overdraft fees right they
essentially took
money from people who didn't have money
uh and what's so interesting about it is
when you start to unpack that data
a lot of those overdraft fees are not
because the people didn't have the money
it's because of exactly what you're
addressing here which is
uh you know they just have expenses that
occur right before they actually get
paid
so uh rent's due on you know the the
12th
uh they've got a car payment on the 13th
the netflix bill hits on the 14th they
get paid on the 15th but somewhere in
there they overdraft and then they're
able to pay off what they owe plus the
overdraft and so
this specific credit product sounds like
you would essentially allow people to
kind of avoid that overdraft situation
um you know by getting access to the
capital early which is uh pretty
impactful
exactly yeah and then talk a little bit
about with that product specifically
uh the whole idea of like accrued days
uh is that a risk
mitigation type uh you know aspect to it
or
or why not kind of front the entire uh
you know pay period uh and only do the
accrued days
well at the moment it's a bit uh risk
mitigation
and then the reason for it is we well
effectively
we sell this product to companies
as a benefit for for their employees
and because it's not a credit product so
we
actually can advance to people what they
actually earned
if we would advance people you know much
more compared to what they earned it
would be a credit product
got it so really what you're doing is
you're essentially building
infrastructure
you're going to the corporations you're
saying hey here's a great product that
you should offer to your
employees as a perk and then your
relationship is with the corporation not
directly with the
individual uh employee so it's kind of a
b to b to c
type product more so than a b2c product
exactly
yeah it makes uh makes a ton of sense um
talk to me about
plans in the united states uh so you
guys have come to the united states
you've applied for the banking license
anything specific in the u.s that you're
focused on or
are specifically excited about so we're
still building uh the product for years
so ultimately the product should be at
par compared to our european product
very shortly and then initially we want
to start
targeting the whole expat community in
the u.s
so there are at least 40 40 to 45
million people in u.s
who are not from u.s originally and who
still have
a lot of connections abroad so our
product allows them to have
on day one global account and b allows
them to
send and receive money from europe from
australia from japan from india
instantly and for free avoiding any any
fees
plus on top of it if they want you know
to trade stocks crypto
we're doing it at uh better pricing
compared to local stock brokers
yeah makes uh makes a ton of sense
before we get into the rapid fire
questions to finish up
uh i'm always fascinated by people who
spend all day uh building financial
technology like yourself
uh what's your personal portfolio look
like in terms of
uh are you mostly allocated to cash to
stocks to crypto just how do you think
about investing your own money
um across all these various asset
classes
yeah good question uh to be honest here
i mean obviously now majority of my
holdings are actually the revolut stocks
which are
private and not not tradable uh
in terms of stocks i i i generally look
at top
five tech companies and then i'm a long
only
and then uh crypto wise uh well
to be honest you lost one half years i
didn't do much because you know
sorry you know price is too high and
then it went even higher even higher
mouth crashed
but i didn't do anything yeah it's uh
it's one of these weird things where uh
people always forget technology
entrepreneurs for the most part that uh
the idea that 90 you know plus percent
of their net worth is tied up in the
illiquid stock of their company is
always true
but uh but but obviously you've made a a
great bet there and uh and the companies
continue to accrue value so i think
you're doing just fine
uh but uh but but pretty cool um all
right i always ask the same three
questions to uh to wrap
up and then you'll get to ask me one
question to uh to finish this up
uh the first is what is the most
important book that you've ever read
well good question i'm i'm unprepared
to balance your last 10 years i think
you know the most enjoyable book i i
read
maybe the last 15 years was the
principles by ray dalio
but then back then it wasn't even
published it was a simple pdf within a
few 50
60 pages which was actually much more
brutal and wholeness compared to
to your book there was well there was a
kind of written with three or four
hundred pages right and the book is so
pr polish that you know i didn't really
recognize the initial pdfs that i read
and i joined
the pdf i could not agree more the pdf
is way better it's way shorter it's much
more direct
uh and frankly much more valuable so uh
that's a great
uh insight but i think the pdf people
can still get uh
if not then you gotta go read the book
and uh suffer through 400 pages rather
than 50 or 60. but i couldn't agree more
there
second question is around sleep schedule
so i used to sleep five or six hours
uh you know kind of badge of honor of
not sleeping a lot
uh but my friends over at eight sleep
sent me a uh kind of thermo-regulated
bed so i basically could turn it super
cold now i sleep like eight or nine
hours and completely changed
uh the way that i thought about sleep
what's your sleep schedule and how has
that evolved over time as the business
has gotten larger
to be honest i used to be the same right
i used to sleep for
five six hours you know because you know
i spent a lot of time in on
travel as well or and on
external meetings but then during
coverage i completely switched to
eight eight hours so i i effectively
go to bed early i get up earlier uh at
the training
uh and then similar to you you know
probably a
cold temperature in the room
you said you go to bed early what time
do you usually try to get to sleep bye
well i usually tell you oh yeah yeah so
so
uh early by uh tech standards but normal
by uh the rest of the world's standards
[Laughter]
uh third question is aliens are you a
believer
or a non-believer i think
probabilistically believer right i think
they're
most likely given the whole universe i
mean uh
billions of you know stars are there
probability
of uh of some kind of for
natural or connections you know between
you know
molecules to enable creation of dncar in
overtime
uh it's very very probable so i i
i believe yeah i tend to agree with you
that uh
uh it's more likely than not which which
is frankly all we could ask for
uh the bigger question i guess is just
like will we come in contact with them
during my or your lifetime but uh
that i'm less confident of right they're
out there but uh maybe too far away for
us
um you could ask me one question to wrap
us up here what
one question you have for me
or what do you enjoy the most
in your podcast yeah i mean look it's
this
what do you enjoy you know when you
speak with people what do you enjoy the
most
it's frankly uh you know you spend all
day thinking about
uh a very specific vertical in the world
right you talked earlier about
uh you're you're not focused on u.s
technology or asia technology firms or
whatever you're focused on
how do we build the best software become
the best kind of financial services
application for our users be number one
and then make sure that the economics of
the uh kind of p l
stay number one as well and so it's
fascinating that uh
you know you and i can talk and uh i can
basically glean a lot of the information
that
you spend all day thinking about um and
so when you do that over and over and
over again across different verticals
you find that you just learn a lot right
and so you know
easy learning already just on top of my
head was when you were talking about the
fact that the
crypto accounts uh kind of have seen 2x
the
inflows to the stock accounts right i
think that most people would
would think that oh the stock market's
much larger stock market is more likely
to uh
kind of have folks interested uh but
given the user base that you have and
kind of the year
um that we saw over the last 12 months
uh it's just fascinating to me how
popular crypto has gotten so quickly
um and so it's little things like that
which you know not groundbreaking on
their own
but when you can start to piece that
together through many conversations
uh you start to just get a more nuanced
uh kind of detailed version of the world
uh which i think it you know makes you
better investor makes you much
kind of just more well-rounded as well
yeah makes sense all right where can we
send people to find you on the internet
or
or learn more about revolut you have a
twitter account
yeah at m
and obviously website private.com all
right so revolut.com or
or your twitter account the two best
places
awesome well listen thank you so much
for taking the time to do this and we'll
definitely have to do it again in the
future
thank you see you